the jungles of Colombia South
America this is where the legend of Al
Dorado was born Spanish cisors they
heard these local Tales of a King near
here who was covered in gold dust and
then the story it just kept growing to
describe entire cities covered in this
stuff deep in the jungle high in the
mountains while the Spanish never found
those fabled
civilizations they also didn't have the
technology that we had have
today my name is Albert
Lynn and I look at the world in a unique
way I use 21st Century Technologies to
look back into our past check that out I
can actually fly through the secret
ancient
world lasers that scan
deserts strip away dense jungle canopy
and scour the oceans to uncover the
Hidden Worlds
beneath we're waiting into uncharted
waters now I have the military helping
me find lost cities new discoveries in
the most a inspiring places on Earth
that's where pixels become reality that
fill the gaps in our story who we are
where we came from and the Wonders we
can
achieve here we are in the 13th
century this is carved out of the earth
huh this is the new Golden Age of
Exploration we know their
secrets the mountain ranges are so steep
the whole area is almost entirely cut
off from the
outside like a lost
world over the past 50 years the whole
area was mostly dominated by local drug
lords and the far
gorillas but now that archaeologists are
beginning to make their way back in
they're finding traces of these
unbelievable civilizations once not
totally
lost
wow it's literally a city in the clouds
maybe the ban stories weren't just
Legends because that's what a real lost
city looks like one2 that's CAD pida the
lost
city CAD prida the lost city is high up
in Columbia's most isolated mountain
range the Sierra
Nevada archaeologists have spent decades
exploring this dense jungle to find out
about the people who lived here here
over 500 years
ago digital technology will help them
reveal more and
faster only the world's toughest
archaeologists can handle this terrain
Santiago Heraldo has been Excavating
here for 20
years it's a beautiful
place
it's amazing this place is still
standing who discovered it it was guacos
looters and then the archaeologist came
in took them about a week to get here
and uh they were led by uh other looters
looters led the way huh yeah it's
actually pretty incredible because they
were they got into a shotgun fight the
looters were after the Gold that's in
the
burials and one looter came out with uh
you know more than 80 pieces of gold
from one burial oh
yeah gunfights for gold archaeology gets
dangerous when gold is involved and this
place is bursting with it who built all
this there was a people that we called
the tyona their predecessors began to be
built around 600
AD it's
[Music]
huge
how many people would have lived here
about 2 to 3,000 at its
peak and then about 10,000 people living
in the upper part of the Basin 10,000
yeah all that Forest that you see would
have been all
[Music]
Farmland oh man you can almost feel
their energy here you know like all
these people running
around
[Music]
it's taken us over 40 years of work to
clear out and Survey as a site trying to
tease out what these people were
thinking when they were building
it 40
years the reason why soon becomes
clear travel out here is
intense Santiago and I had for CAD
Antigua a recently discovered tyrona
site it's only like 12 km 7.5 miles or
so from CAD P where we just came from
that's if you took a straight line that
is kills your guts it's a real gut
Banger this
thing come
on we just had a helicopter now we're in
a
4x4 and we still got to foot it through
some of the craziest
jungle the tyrona built their homes on
the steepest Ridges of this thick dense
jungle from here they could see
everything around them
safe in the mountains they remained
hidden for
centuries they're one of the most
mysterious people in all of South
America and finding their ancient cities
in this terrain it's almost
[Music]
impossible
these roots are incredible yeah it's a
it's fig
tree this is what I wanted to show you
see that right there the Rocks see that
yeah yeah is that a wall yeah that's a
wall W it's a taona wall
so that's how we find them out here you
wouldn't even see it I mean honestly it
looks like a pile of rocks no for the
most part that's to the untrained eye
that's what they look like but uh but
yeah that's
wall wow it's
incredible I mean you barely recognize
it well you know we've got like 400
years of uh growth and leaf litter and
soil how long did it take to find this
place uh after SE podo hunt oh it was it
was a good like 14 15 years around 1989
1990 15 years yeah lots of walking lot
of bush whacking I think there's a
better way to do this you know we could
use aial lar could a digital model the
whole place then we could remove the
trees and see the ground we could find
the pathways The Rock piles that would
be amazing if it if it does pick up
these Terraces it would be really really
amazing it would be fabulous maybe we'll
even find some new
ones lar should be able to strip away
the trees to expose the ground beneath
them across this whole area including
terrain that has yet to be
explored the lar scanner shoots about
400,000 laser pulses every second each
pulse creates an accurate distance
measurement
which we can use to build a 3D
model however there's a problem the
whole jungle here is incredibly
thick to test my technology first we'll
scan a small area around CAD
pida if that works we can scan the whole
valley this has never been tried here
before
or in totally Uncharted
Territory we don't know what we'll find
it could be more lost cities or it could
be
nothing but what we do know is that this
chance is just too good to
[Music]
miss not much is known about the tyrona
but what we do know comes from the
Spanish Invaders who arrived in the 16th
century
these
streams they run all the way down to the
coast of the Caribbean it's about 15
miles or so as the crow flies that's the
same Coastline where the Spanish first
landed in
1501 you know they were looking for
gold and they found it and there's
this Spanish friy and he describes the
tyrona in this way they had feathered
ornaments worn on top of huge plaques of
polished gold there was no Indian male
or female that would not have sets of
jewelry containing ear ornaments
necklaces nose rings and crowns all of
them made in
Gold those first encounters with the
gold Laden tyrona sparked the myth of
Eldorado but this myth has its roots in
fact there is gold in these
[Music]
Hills you see a tiny little Flash
but when the Spanish arrived and they
saw that everyone was wearing gold
ornaments they thought that these
mountains bled gold that's that's actual
gold little tiny tiny little Flex yeah
right there look at that that's gold
they're microscopic
almost
wow with the tyrona have used these
kinds of pools to find it we don't know
how it was uh you know
so to speak probably panned and you know
collected tiny bit by tiny bit until
they had enough to make one of the gold
or moments the Spanish conquistadors
they were obsessed by the tyrona gold
there's not much of it left looters have
seen to that but there is a stash kept
hidden away in a vault in
[Music]
Bata
Bogata
Colombia I've got behind the scenes
access to a vault of tyrona gold at the
Bano de la republ gold
[Music]
museum look at all
this I'm meeting Dr Juanita sser an
expert in tyrona
jewelry this is tyrona gold yes this
tyrona gold work they're so
detailed these are a pair of earrings
they were used just like these I look
does it look good on me yes it looks
very nice it's pretty
big this is so intricate look at that
well this is a great
pendant it might represent a a man and a
bat and a bird as well let me show you
in the
microscope and here you can see the
details that's amazing they're tiny
little feet holding on upside down yes
it's so cool but also this this in here
some tiny little
birds
these details are literally you know the
thickness of your hair that's what it
looks like wrapped around in the most
incredible weaved
patterns
[Music]
unbelievable wow what is that this is a
necklace you want to can I hold it wow
wow it's heavy
yeah look at
that I have my head here between this
piece of jewelry and I actually realized
that some human four or 500 years ago
wore this exact piece just like
this is this pure gold no it's not pure
it's an alloy made out of gold copper
and silver these are these are gilded
pieces so how thin is the gold layer on
the exterior well we I can show you in
here this like a Sandy or porous lar in
here it measures
5.8 microns wow that's incredible that's
incredible the tyrona metal Smith melted
together gold copper and silver to make
an alloy once set the piece was burned
over a flame and then dipped in acid
solution made from a local
herb these chemical processes brought
the gold comp compounds to the surface
creating a gilded
exterior so basically the Spanish show
up they see all this stuff they think
it's gold but actually it's just got
this layer on the very exterior the
thickness of a of a spider's web that is
actually gold and that's it yes I guess
the the Spanish didn't know that at
first right no they thought it was all
gold the tyrona were able to craft
complex pieces out of tiny amounts of
gold but it was just enough to fuel the
spaniard's
fantasies back at CAD pra it's the
Moment of Truth the light R test Skins
are in and if it worked will you'll be
able to see the world of the tyrona like
never
before hey man oh great the data is in
yeah check this out you going to like
this oh
wow okay I've never seen it without the
trees well yeah unless you cut them all
down then I can actually change the
angle of the sun here this is wonderful
look at
that but you can see all the
paths these paths they follow the
terrain off of this
Central Terrace on the Main Ridge and
they kind of go out in every
direction web of Pathways yeah you can
continue like drawing these out and
because it's all about
connection it's not like anything I've
ever seen in any other city it's I
there's no walls There's No Boundaries
there's no squares it's nothing it's all
open it almost looks like this neural
network yeah how long has this place
been abandoned for oh just about since
1600 so 100 years ago yeah there's been
jungle growing over this for 400 years
how is it still standing oh these guys
were wonderful Engineers they really
were and and good design really stands
the test of time design what do you mean
you've got so much rain out here it's
just
ridiculous we've got over 4 meters of
rain per year so 4 M yeah like 12 13 ft
yep that's exactly right it just rain
cats and dogs
how would that not just erode and
destroy all of those a good portion of
the engineering and the design and the
architecture is meant to work as a water
management
system we would to have the roof right
and then all that water would have
course down down
staircases and so you've got runoff
water moving very rapidly down slope and
just make it all try again very
quickly the whole thing was designed as
a massive gutter system also that's
awesome yeah that's what has preserved
the site
actually using the liar data we built a
3D model of CAD
pra and look at this
W
boom without the trees we can see sad PR
as it was 500 years ago transported
through time we can move through the
city following the footsteps of the
people that once lived here
oh this is amazing we've got like the
center part of the town and then all
these paths to lead out to it and
connect to the other neighborhoods
imagine we've got dogs you've got kids
playing you've got goldsmiths Weavers
we've got
Merchants we've proved that lar works
here now we're going to scan the whole
valley who knows what we will find
hidden beneath the jungle
canopy the test scans of c. prita Pro
that the Light Art technology does work
here now we're going to scan the
valley if there are any other tyrona
cities hidden under the jungle we'll
find
them okay so this is the sier Nevada
range yeah this is this is the northern
portion you can see it goes from the
Caribbean up to snow caps pretty quickly
I've pulled up a satellite map so
Santiago and I can work out where to
scan going rotate around so we can see
the whole valley here all right that's
the whole Basin that's lower portion
upper portion and we got to right there
okay so it' be kind of good to scan this
whole area here what if we start off
with this region here that would be
perfect that would be perfect
yeah I mean a drone can't carry the
sensor because it's not you know it's
too heavy um supplies are brought in to
sad Pita every month via helicopter
right yeah yeah that's right that's
right maybe we can piggy back off of the
helicopter that would be
perfect yeah and then we can have it do
these really tight paths this kind of
grid pattern through this region that
would be perfect that would be perfect
that would be
fantastic we mount an air lar Scanner
with three lenses on a helicopter one
lens faces straight down the other two
are at Angles this maximizes the chance
that some of the laser beams will make
it through the canopy to the
[Music]
ground the aerial liar team gets to work
scanning and processing billions of data
points from the
valley
there's a clue to what the lighter scans
might find underneath the tree
canopy it's at the entrance to CAD
[Music]
Bida what is this well we call it the
mapstone a
mapstone look at these lines are these
Pathways we think so look at these
radiating little hubs here what are
these are these it looks a bit like the
pattern that you see inside Z where
you've got like Central areas and
radiating paths that lead in and out of
the central area but we don't know
exactly what it Maps out or what it
represents see if we can match anything
with the ground scan okay ready first
I'll take a
picture and then I'm going to Overlay
the ground
scan okay let's see this is the rock
obviously and this is C got the Central
Area the Terrace is right here doesn't
really fit this at all try it out at a
different scale if you if we
reduce you think reducing
yeah so you think it could be like
smaller smaller
smaller yeah there we go something like
this around here yeah you can see that
it's sort of at a different
scale different scale yeah if if it's a
map it represents a wider area doesn't
really fit the town as
such Santiago's
right there may be more cities to find
out
[Music]
there there is a pathway out of CAD
prida it's a staircase made out of
1200 Stone steps heading towards the sea
it's an intriguing lead need to follow
[Music]
up I've come down to the coast to meet
Anthropologist Eduardo
MAA this is where the legend of El
Dorado
began I didn't realize that the tyrona
had a life here in the ocean
I've been up in the mountains but they
were here too yeah along the seashore is
the taona would have had small villages
where they would trade with the people
in the higher lands what would they
trade fish brought from the sea salt and
sea shells from the lowlands and in the
highlands they would have very refined
textiles gold ornaments and
ceramic so the Spaniards came here
greedy for gold they saw gold moving
from the mountains down to the coastline
and fish moving back and forth did they
ever try to work together did they trade
with each other the Spanish and the
tyrona they did they did
trade but from the first period of
contact the Spaniards had this Gold
Fever so what happened here the
Spaniards had guns and cannons but
besides that they had a sort of
biological weapon
diseases tyus influenza small pox
diseases which were new in the Americas
and led to a of
Apocalypse so the diseases they brought
over on the backs of their own greed
ended up wiping out almost this entire
population practically the high death
TOS were due to disease more than
Warfare the few survivors that weren't
infected with disease and weren't
enslaved fled into the
mountains
and even though those Spanish
conquistadors were so
horrendous and so destructive some must
have survived for that you should be
some indigenous people who claim to be
the descendants of the
tyrona they still have same myths of
origin and some of their
Customs the indigenous population still
live deep within the jungle covered
mountains
today I'm going to meet them to find out
what they say happened to the tyrona and
their
gold high up in the mountains near CAD
pra are the kogi they claim to be
descendants of the
tyrona Santiago introduces me to Jose
Maria he's a kogi priest
every culture has a origin story could
you tell me
[Music]
yours do you think all the fathers and
mothers of your people go back to the
time of the tyrona they go back to the
tyrona itself
mhm do you think that they live in a
similar way to how you live
today it seems like for many years from
the time of the story of El Dorado till
now there's been a lot of people who
have come here in search of
gold
because people took gold from the
mountains the kogi believe gold lust has
devastated their culture and the culture
of their
ancestors the
tyrona but there's still traces of
tyrona Heritage here that can't be seen
at sad
pida
Jose Maria gives me his Blessing to
preserve it in the best way I know
how the lar scanner captures data points
which build an accurate model of the Ki
Huts back at CAD PR I used my technology
to bring the scans of the kogi Huts to
life this is so cool
just feels like we're just peering back
into time back to the time that the last
tyrona lived here about 400 years
ago it's kind of like making the
invisible
[Music]
visible this technology allows us to see
the city as a tyrona would have
done finally the aerial liar team has
finished processing billions of data
points from the scans of the Valley now
we can uncover all of the mountains in
the tyron's
world here it
is light data is in yeah this is the
whole oh my God okay I've sprayed it up
against the wall so let me take a look
so that's c p here yeah this is c
p everything that you see in white
that's
flat that's what we're looking for
that's the signatures yeah cuz white
means flat flat means humans and that
means terracing so what we're looking
for is
white oh look look look look you can see
right there the path that leads up River
can you pull out a bit more okay oh I
want to see more I want to see
more see if we can find some new areas
[Music]
oh look this this is new this is
absolutely new right there this is new
this area right
here right there right there that rid
line right there this area right
there see that it's nice and flat highly
probable that there's Terraces right
there uh this is this we've never been
there so you're telling me that this
area up here could be an entirely new
city could it could be a new site could
be a new site could be a new town this
is this is fantastic data a lost city in
the mountains that you've never seen
before could be but we need to ground
Tru
them we got to put boots on the ground
and head out there
and see for ourselves whether there's
terracing and walls and just man-made
structures
that's that's where pixels become
reality somewhere out there there's a
lost city waiting to be
found
this is going to be
tough we'll be bushwacking through some
of the world's roughest
terrain Santiago and I head off with the
camera
crew we've got the Colombian military
with us because Bandits still roam this
jungle and we can't take any
chances before we can even start the
climb there's a long Trek on the old
tyrona path
then it's hours of bushwacking up the
ridge we spotted on the lar
scans our goal is to get to the top of
the ridge where the lighter showed large
flat areas that we hope are the signs of
a tyrona
[Music]
city it starts so
well
wow it's just so
beautiful but it's not long before the
real challenge begins how many machetes
do we have among the crew got three four
four
machetes just take turn
okay we're going to be going
up
trying to find a trail right by the side
well let me pull out the
data okay f
up
okay okay pull down so we are we are
right here right here right
there at 336 6 altitude 3366 ft okay
we've got about 700 ft to go
up the ridge line right up there
somewhere the going up like
that and if all goes well we're going be
heading up this Ridge line or right
beside it up up up toward this Plateau
up
here we're literally following a map
made by lasers in the sky to the
thickest jungle I've ever seen to look
for new Lost Cities good
fun this is just the beginning ahead of
us is a 700 ft vertical climb on
whatever pathway we can cut out of the
harsh
jungle we leave the old tyrona path and
start to fight our way up the
mountain looks like the trajectory kind
of follows this Ridge up that way yeah
should think the S is pretty
loose
oh
man this is why jungle Archaeology is so
hard deadly snakes are in this jungle if
anyone is bitten they'll die before we
can get them
[Music]
out
this climb is harder than we could have
ever
[Music]
imagined sorry oh oh
oh you
right after a brutal climb we finally
have a
breakthrough oh there we
go don't
just go out a pottery up here Pottery
yeah are you serious yeah yeah yeah yeah
look at
that see bits and pieces of pottery
right there oh yeah look at that
see can you get the TR out please yeah
here we
go ancient Pottery see this one right
there with this
Pottery there's human being
this is tyrona Pottery that's so
cool guys come on
up we got another one up here you got
another one yeah we got another one up
here another
one it hasn't been looted there's no
loter
pits no looter pits means that this is
an untouched
sight what is it
lip a a pot lip
yeah wow look at
this it's on a slope so it's coming from
uphill look at that right there right
down the
side proof of of Life The Lost
Civilization consumed by the
[Music]
jungle we follow the trail of pottery
uphill it's like everywhere you grab
something's trying to poke you or sting
you
this like jungle exploration meets
mountain
climbing hard
work
Whata we got a Terrace up here come on
you got a Terrace yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah found a
Terrace what yeah yeah yeah all right
yeah you can see the wall right here
here let clear that a
bit see right there let me
see yeah there it is see wall wall right
here let me
[Music]
see see the Big Blocks of stone right
here
mhm and here the plink of stone stone St
Stone right here more Stone right
here
Stone so you've never seen this before
no we've never seen this
before wow found three four five pares
yeah all
right these Terraces are a sign that the
tyrona were once here right there but
the site we spotted on the lar scan is
still far above us or not even even
halfway
there let's
go the Mountain's getting steeper and
we're climbing at a 52°
incline the humidity is reaching
100 you
okay you all right this climb is
unrelenting we're all
struggling it's merciless and
unforgiving come on we go up we
go you see anything no yeah
we're at
ft for what yeah just over 4,000 we got
to be getting close okay come on let's
go if there's a city here the that it
will have been built on a huge
artificially flat
space the white areas we saw in the lar
scans you see anything oh yeah is we're
finding out so want ter it's it's we've
got we've got a lot of we've got a lot
of forest over at
but
yeah that's all nice and flat the flat
area looks like it could be a tyrona
Terrace but to be sure we need evidence
Pottery cut Stones anything to show that
tyrona actually lived
here the Hunt's on
we spread out checking every inch of
ground even the Army joins
in maybe around the edges yeah probably
around the edges I mean we need to
spread out and see if we can find some
walls watch out yeah yeah watch out for
snakes without cold hard proof that the
tyrona were here will have done all this
for
nothing and it makes sense right it's
flat but we haven't seen any evidence
yet right at the top of the ridge now
you know if it's consistent with
everything else around here this would
have been where a tyrona city would have
stood you got to find some evidence
Beyond just the
[Music]
topography
I see a rock right
here this is a piece of Cut Rock just
like a sudad
p following it let's see if we can see
it on the other side of this
tree you see it over
there yeah it continues over here
good yeah yeah this yeah we got that one
right there
yeah another piece of cut rock you think
this is the edge of a Terrace uh yeah I
mean we've got the lung of that way the
line goes that way so that's that's why
we got that flat area right inside this
is what we're looking for the edges
Stone after Stone after
Stone yeah yeah we got another one over
here you got another one yeah we got
another one
yeah I think we found it down I think we
found it I've got Pottery what yeah you
serious got potery yeah
yeah definely let me see it's a really
small piece can you get some water and
uh clean it up but yeah poy for sure wow
look at that the tiniest
fragment but it's enough that was going
to be fun to excavate
C for sure this was once somebody's
home this city would have been part of
the Great tyrona civilization from
Mountain Toops to the
Sea the lar scans uncovered this
extraordinary Place reclaimed by nature
and hidden under the jungle for hundreds
of years and this is just the
beginning with this technology you can
discover dozens of new cities and
possibly the whole tyrona
civilization I think we can call that
success
yeah pretty good
[Music]
day